everybody always tells me I look like
Angie Bassett and I've always done an
impression of Angela Bassett like I do
too so there's one impression I do from
a American Dream the Michael Jackson
story where she finds out that her
husband's been cheating on her and she
like answers the phone and hears him on
the other line talking to somebody
talking about Joe Joe is like cheating
on her and she's like he comes back into
the house he's like hey baby and she's
like you will lie
and you would cheat
and I don't want you I don't want you I
don't want you no more and with Angela
it's all in the lips it's all in the
lips and it's the same thing with What's
Love Got to Do With It when she's
talking to her friend and her friend is
like not messing around with Laurence
Fishburne's character Ike Turner she's
like not dealing with him being abused
and she's like you ain't got to hit me
but watch and then answer the best is
like so yeah
it's okay I'm sure that that's probably
what they were trying to like remember
when they must have searched that